6.004 students work around the dryer bottleneck
by finding a laundromat that has two dryers
for every washer.
Looking at the timeline you can see the plan,
which is divided into 30-minute steps.
The washer is in use every step, producing
a newly-washed load every 30 minutes.
Dryer usage is interleaved, where Dryer #1
is used to dry the odd-numbered loads and
Dryer #2 is used to dry the even-numbered
loads.
Once started, a dryer runs for a duration
of two steps, a total of 60 minutes.
Since the dryers run on a staggered schedule,
the system as a whole produces a load of clean,
dry laundry every 30 minutes.
The steady-state throughput is 1 load of laundry
every 30 minutes and the latency for a particular
load of laundry is 90 minutes.
And now here's the take-home message from
this example.
Consider the operation of the two-dryer system.
Even though the component dryers themselves
aren't pipelined, the two-dryer interleaving
system is acting like a 2-stage pipeline with
a clock period of 30 minutes and a latency
of 60 minutes.
In other words, by interleaving the operation
of 2 unpipelined components we can achieve
the effect of a 2-stage pipeline.
Returning to the example of the previous section,
we couldn't improve the throughput of our
pipelined system past 1/8 ns because the minimum
clock period was set by the 8 ns latency of
the C module.
To improve the throughput further we either
need to find a pipelined version of the C
component or use an interleaving strategy
to achieve the effect of a 2-stage pipeline
using two instances of the unpipelined C component.
Let's try that…
Here's a circuit for a general-purpose two-way
interleaver, using, in this case, two copies
of the unpipelined C component, C_0 and C_1.
The input for each C component comes from
a D-latch, which has the job of capturing
and holding the input value.
There's also a multiplexer to select which
C-component output will be captured by the
output register.
In the lower left-hand corner of the circuit
is a very simple 2-state FSM with one state
bit.
The next-state logic is a single inverter,
which causes the state to alternate between
0 and 1 on successive clock cycles.
This timing diagram shows how the state bit
changes right after each rising clock edge.
To help us understand the circuit, we'll look
at some signal waveforms to illustrate its
operation.
To start, here are the waveforms for the CLK
signal and our FSM state bit from the previous
slide.
A new X input arrives from the previous stage
just after the rising edge of the clock.
Next, let's follow the operation of the C_0
component.
Its input latch is open when FSM Q is low,
so the newly arriving X_1 input passes through
the latch and C_0 can begin its computation,
producing its result at the end of clock cycle
#2.
Note that the C_0 input latch closes at the
beginning of the second clock cycle, holding
the X_1 input value stable even though the
X input is starting to change.
The effect is that C_0 has a valid and stable
input for the better part of 2 clock cycles
giving it enough time to compute its result.
The C_1 waveforms are similar, just shifted
by one clock cycle.
C_1's input latch is open when FSM Q is high,
so the newly arriving X_2 input passes through
the latch and C_1 can begin its computation,
producing its result at the end of clock cycle
#3.
Now let's check the output of the multiplexer.
When FSM Q is high, it selects the value from
C_0 and when FSM Q is low, it selects the
value from C_1.
We can see that happening in the waveform
shown.
Finally, at the rising edge of the clock,
the output register captures the value on
its input and holds it stable for the remainder
of the clock cycle.
The behavior of the interleaving circuit is
like a 2-stage pipeline: the input value arriving
in cycle i is processed over two clock cycles
and the result output becomes available on
cycle i+2.
What about the clock period for the interleaving
system?
Well, there is some time lost to the propagation
delays of the upstream pipeline register that
supplies the X input, the internal latches
and multiplexer, and the setup time of the
output register.
So the clock cycle has to be just a little
bit longer than half the propagation delay
of the C module.
We can treat the interleaving circuit as a
2-stage pipeline, consuming an input value
every clock cycle and producing a result two
cycles later.
When incorporating an N-way interleaved component
in our pipeline diagrams, we treat it just
like a N-stage pipeline.
So N of our pipelining contours have to pass
through the component.
Here we've replaced the slow unpipelined C
component with a 2-way interleaved C-prime
component.
We can follow our process for drawing pipeline
contours.
First we draw a contour across all the outputs.
Then we add contours, ensuring that two of
them pass through the C-prime component.
Then we add pipeline registers at the intersections
of the contours with the signal connections.
We see that the contours passing through C-prime
have caused extra pipeline registers to be
added on the other inputs to the F module,
accommodating the 2-cycle delay through C-prime.
Somewhat optimistically we've specified the
C-prime minimum t_CLK to be 4 ns, so that
means that the slow component which determines
the system's clock period is now the F module,
with a propagation delay of 5 ns.
So the throughput of our new pipelined circuit
is 1 output every 5 ns, and with 5 contours,
it's a 5-pipeline so the latency is 5 times
the clock period or 25 ns.
By running pipelined systems in parallel we
can continue to increase the throughput.
Here we show a laundry with 2 washers and
4 dryers, essentially just two copies of the
1-washer, 2-dryer system shown earlier.
The operation is as described before, except
that at each step the system produces and
consumes two loads of laundry.
So the throughput is 2 loads every 30 minutes
for an effective rate of 1 load every 15 minutes.
The latency for a load hasn't changed; it's
still 90 minutes per load.
We've seen that even with slow components
we can use interleaving and parallelism to
continue to increase throughput.
Is there an upper bound on the throughput
we can achieve?
Yes!
The timing overhead of the pipeline registers
and interleaving components will set a lower
bound on the achievable clock period, thus
setting an upper bound on the achievable throughput.
Sorry, no infinite speed-up is possible in
the real world.